three different people want me to play
traxler
i don't even know how to play the track
sir bro
but i can try it anyway
so in order for there to be a track
sword white has to play this and then i
play two nights
which we're not gonna get we have a
spanish
um and it's been a while since i played
the black side with spanish
because i usually just go for stafford
keep clapping
m get the w so i'll probably play with a
debating whether to play a6 no i'll play
f5
this is uh more fun content this might
be the youtube thumbnail
i guess with a youtube thumbnail i
usually have the arrow and the other
arrow
um i did go through a phase of playing
this years ago
and bishop takes c6 is not the most
popular move
more players will like the two main
lines are knight c3 or d3
um but yeah this is very concrete
the one thing i remember about this line
is that queen h or a queen d4 can be
played
and the queen on d4 in some variation
will be useful because it defends the
rook on h8
so the point is if white plays queen h5
g6 the traditional tactic doesn't work
for white
because after i take my queen defends
the rook
actually once the knight moves away the
queen defends
so i'm basically guaranteed to win back
upon
oh no white has a tactic to win my rook
yeah i think actually queen h5 is
probably a blunder
because now the queen's attacked and the
knights attacked
ah my rook oh no
okay of course white uh yeah this is
probably the best practical try after
queen
h5 and it's still it's still interesting
because white
won a bunch of my pawns i'm losing
casting rights
um actually on the surface this looks
like a
kind of scary position because i i'm
underdeveloped i'm my king's in the
center
pretty naked um
but hopefully we'll see the value in
having an extra minor piece
especially in the position that's um
it's beginning to open up
for some reason i was hallucinating
white could play bishop g5 but the pawn
still on d2
usually the d-pawns move by now
okay so there's a little bit of time to
compliment us
thanks for all of the content babies oh
yeah
according to my sub badge i need to
update my sub badges
okay so i'm contemplating um what to do
i mean white castle which is very
natural move
but now there's a lot of potential
because i have the half bulb in each
file
my queen's in play i can develop with
tempo i think i'll just start with this
like usually when you can bring a piece
into the game and make a threat
you can usually just do it quickly
because i'm preventing white from doing
anything here on the queen side
and i can keep developing with tempo
should also consider the maiden one
threat
um queen e5 is met with
f4 i mean i could also take a pawn but
i'm more interested in
just developing my pieces first
so i hit the queen my queen's still
useful kind of covering these squares
white tween is close to not quite
trapped
has the square of the square
i guess there's a small trick if white
tries to counterattack
uh i can also do that but oh no white's
queen
yeah um unfortunate plunder from white
it was already kind of a difficult
position
[Music]
i was looking forward to maybe having a
slightly more challenging game
i was going to say that if white played
c3 after 97 i
would probably have this move uh f4
maybe i'll just win d3
and win e4
life is good thanks for the bits a b q
zack
oh should i counter botez gabit
i want to be responsible though
yeah there's probably a better way to
to get things done here um we're going
to put the queen
i want to put it here because white
moves to f3
man maybe i do wait no i don't sack my
queen
i'm taking a lot of time here i'm just
gonna play um
a safe move go for f4 soon
oh okay some possibility of
of counter gamuting
actually yeah like takes takes i'm
getting
enough material for it
i'll be up a rook and a bishop and
another bishop
oh no my queen
i'll still have some like fun attack
hopefully
why has one legal move
oh there's a cool line that's fun when
like all the pieces are
aimed towards the the king side okay
let's attack the thing
the knight is basically trapped
also fun puzzle if knight f3 black to
move and made in two
like force made into
okay this isn't as fun yeah if knight f3
i had rook h3
takes and then may or knight h2 and then
mate
okay so two legal moves
i guess this defends the rook then i'll
play this move
prompting white to walk into the pin
and i don't want to play with my food
again
so tired i just want to um
i probably want to bring the other rook
in
to yeah i'm inviting all the pieces to
the party again
because i think that's the most
efficient way to meet okay let's get rid
of the knight
and do this
okay so it's very close to force mates
there we go okay
so um i guess that game lasted longer
than
uh expected but um
yeah for anyone who wants maybe a a
weird exotic line against the spanish
this is known as the schliemann defense
it also goes by the yanish like
j-a-e-n-i-c-h
i-s-c-h um
i learned it years ago i used to watch
like before watching chess on youtube
there is a video series from the
internet chess club
it was a boris alterman gambit guide and
he had like a video series on on this
um just kind of going through the main
lines
and i mean if you if you play this as
black you kind of have to know what
you're doing
uh like here queen d4 is a very
crucial move yeah engine already prefers
black here
anyway i hope this offers some
inspiration this is uh
not a pattern that you see every day
with the queen
defending from far away
so i hope people are inspired if this
goes on youtube hi to youtube